let's chat with people from the audience
so important i want to hear from you
without you i'm a guy in a room and it's
sad and nobody listens
so we do these calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
we're going to start today i hope i'm
pronouncing this correctly
with is it tanya from texas is that the
way it's pronounced
tanya from texas welcome you have to
unmute yourself
i've unmuted you but i can see you have
muted yourself tanya welcome
thank you so much
okay since the 2020 election i have had
a suspicion that the fact that biden won
the white house and republicans won the
senate had something to do with a whole
bunch of new voters coming out and not
voting down ballot well hold on a second
tanya democrats won the senate what do
you mean republicans won the senate i
mean i i mean um i'm
i'm nervous i'm sorry oh you're doing
great
with what everyone was running to
referring to as a mandate to work
together because
um
wait so let's take a step back tanya so
i can figure it out so yes in 2020
joe biden
won the white house and took it from
trump democrats secured the senate with
a 50-50 senate but kamala harris is the
tie-breaking vote and democrats
controlled the house are we on the same
page as far as that goes yes okay so
your question was
there was there was talk about this
mandate for for biden to work together
with the other side because of um
oh
tanya
oh my gosh i'm curious okay i'm gonna
just reduce it to this please your
thoughts on the fact that people need to
vote all the way down the ballot i never
hear anyone talking about it it seems
like it would have consequences
absolutely
we must all vote we must all vote all
the way down the ballot if you show up
and you check a box for senator in
november and then you don't do
congressperson you don't do
gubernatorial you don't do attorney
general secretary of state
state senate all of the i mean listen
you get to you you're going there once
and voting you might as well make your
voice heard on every single one of them
and people not doing that tanya
helps republicans sneak in these
extremists into local office so you
better be do your homework and be ready
to fill out your ballot fully and
completely please
yes i agree and i i wonder why that's
not a major topic of discussion i
appreciate your patience with me thank
you so much tanya it's been a pleasure
things are okay in texas
i'm hanging on in there and i'm i'm i'm
hoping for beto
okay we're all hoping all right thank
you tanya very much appreciate it
an important issue which we landed on
there